have you ever wondered why social
security is absolute garbage every year
they collect 12.4 percent of everybody's
income up to 18 000
yet they're projected to fall short of
their payouts by 2034. some people blame
it on the pandemic others blame it on
bureaucracy and others suggest that it's
simply a side effect of people living
longer than ever before while all of
these are valid points none of these are
the fundamental problem with social
security you see the fundamental problem
with social security is that it
generates no real wealth in 2021 social
security pulled in 1.118 trillion
dollars in income but 1.001 trillion
dollars of that was from contributions
and the 41 billion dollars was from
income tax charged on benefits social
security only generated 76 billion
dollars in investment-based income which
is a measly 2.61 annual return given
that that barely keeps up with long-term
inflation if that it's no wonder why
social security is trash when it comes
to creating real wealth now you don't
actually have to worry about social
security running out because i'm sure
they're going to either increase the tax
rate decrease benefits and or print
money to make up the deficit but what if
there's a better solution
what if instead of investing in low
yielding bonds social security invested
in the stock market real estate and
energy not just in the us but
internationally this would generate true
returns for social security and they
would not be nearly as dependent on
contributions at first glance this might
sound riskier and it is but this is
exactly what sovereign wealth funds
around the world have been doing for
decades and the most successful fund of
the mall is norway's sovereign wealth
fund also known as the oil fund as of
december 2021 the fund boosted a total
of a 1.4 trillion dollars worth of
assets to put that in perspective social
security only controls 2.9 trillion
dollars despite the population being 61
times larger on a per capita basis
social security has 8 825 worth of
assets per person
meanwhile norway boasts a whopping 260
000 worth of assets per person norway
literally has over a quarter million
dollars worth of assets per person
i've been picking on social security
thus far but really norway blows the
rest of the world out of the water as
well
china's wealth fund for example controls
1.1 trillion worth of net assets but
compared to their population that's not
even 1 000 per person so here's how
norway built the most successful
sovereign wealth fund in history
taking a look back the history of
norway's wealth fund dates back to the
year 1960.
save that money was made from the
country's vast oil reserves and norway's
sovereign wealth fund has become one of
the largest single investors around the
world when norway's prime minister einer
gerhartsen got norway involved in the
oil business he gave oil companies from
around the world licenses to come and
search for oil within norway
oil companies were allowed to keep their
profits they generated but they had to
pay petroleum taxes and leases to norway
to continue operations it took a couple
of years to get the ball rolling but
starting in 1966 oil companies flooded
in looking for oil within the next four
years they drilled 37 wells and on the
day before christmas eve in 1969 they
struck oil in the north sea in an oil
field called ecofisk this turned out to
be the largest oil field ever found at
sea and by 1971 oil production would
begin it didn't take long for norway to
start raking in loads of money and soon
enough they started to discuss what to
do with the money this was not a fast
process by any means as it would drag on
for 12 years but eventually in 1983 they
came to a consensus they decided to
create a fund that could invest the
profits generated from the oil industry
hence the name oil fund
the best part was that the government
was only allowed to spend real returns
which are the returns after accounting
for inflation this seems like a
no-brainer but it's not nearly as common
in application we can't give norway too
much praise though given that their
government was just as slow as the rest
of the world it wasn't till 1990 that
norway actually went ahead and created
the fund and it wasn't till 1996 that
the fund received its first cash
injection from the ministry of finance
it took 36 years to get to this point
but at least they did it and now it was
time to invest
one of the hardest parts of running a
successful investment fund is
effectively investing all the capital
even investing moguls like warren
buffett struggle with this issue norway
also fell into this trap early on and
they would end up investing all of their
money into government bonds but
fortunately just one year later they
diversified heavily into equities norway
approved for 40 of their fund's capital
to be invested into equities and they
gave newark's bank investment management
the responsibility of investing the
money within just six months the bank
converted all 40 into equities and with
that they were booming in 2000 norway
approved the fund to diversify into five
emerging markets so norwx had a pretty
broad set of choices when it came to
investments but this didn't mean that
they could just invest in anything
there are four main categories that are
blacklisted from the fund for various
reasons first of all the fund is not
allowed to invest in any weapon
production companies like boeing airbus
or lockheed martin secondly the fund is
not allowed to invest in any tobacco
companies
thirdly the fund is not allowed to
invest in any companies that cause
environmental damage this one is a bit
ironic given that all the money in the
fund originated from oil but i guess
they're limiting their environmental
impact as much as possible
anyway the last major category the fund
is not allowed to invest in is a company
that are notorious for human rights
violations fun fact walmart was
blacklisted for this reason until 2019.
with all these guidelines norway was
chugging along through the 2000s quite
strongly but then the 2008 financial
recession rolled around
in just one year the fund lost 23.31 or
nearly a quarter of all their
investments many people in this
situation would panic and sell all their
stocks but norway wasn't concerned in
fact they were excited and optimistic to
buy the crash in 2007 norway increased
the fund's allocation to equities from
40 to 60
and in 2008 they created a five percent
allocation for real estate honestly they
couldn't have played this any better
they brilliantly bought up the bottom of
the market and they have been rewarded
extremely well in 2009 the fund posted a
25.6 return and the fund has grown 5x
since the recession today the fund
boasts an annualized return of 6.56
percent since inception which is a bit
lower than the s p 500 7-8 return but
the oil fund is 18 times as diversified
as the s p 500 with stakes in 913
companies spread across 73 countries at
the end of every year norway reveals all
of its takes in a massive 400 page
document it would take forever to go
through all these but just giving over
the most notable ones they have 21
billion apple 17 billion dollars in
microsoft 7.8 billion dollars on
facebook and a 14.5 billion on amazon
considering all this i don't think you'd
be surprised to hear that the oil fund
is the largest stock owner in europe and
given how strategically they've played
the market so far i think they more than
deserve that title
having all that money is great and all
but what's the point if you can't spend
it as we previously touched on norway is
allowed to withdraw real returns from
the fund every year but norway didn't
even do this till 2016 when they made
their first withdrawal since the 1990s
norway has averaged about 2 inflation
per year so this would mean that norway
is allowed to withdraw about 4.5 per
year because that's the real annual
return but they don't even allow for
that norway limits its withdrawals to
three percent per year which is very
similar to the four percent rule with
the s p 500. the rule goes that if you
withdraw four percent or less every year
from an investment in the s p 500 you'll
never run out of money so it's again
quite smart that norway has limited
withdrawals to three percent
after all you don't want to kill the
golden goose when the country needs
money though norway doesn't hesitate to
take out the full three percent in 2020
for example norway withdrew 37 billion
dollars from the fund to battle the
pandemic anyway looking forward norway
predicts that the worst case scenario
for the fund in 2030 is 455 billion
dollars and that the best case scenario
is 3.3 trillion dollars if the best case
scenario plays out the oil fund would
overtake social security in assets in
the second half of this decade and at
that rate the fund would have 1 million
per citizen by 2040. having said that
there's no question that the oil fund is
a massive success financially but
critics argue that the fund isn't nearly
as successful when it comes to ethics
probably the biggest criticism against
the oil fund is that all of its
contributions are derived from oil but
the truth is if norway didn't take
advantage of the demand for oil someone
else would have filled the gap over the
past six years it simply wasn't feasible
to produce renewable energy on such a
large scale so if norway avoided oil
it's not like customers would have
switched to renewable energy they would
have just gone to saudi arabia or canada
for oil and these countries have plenty
of oil to make up for the disparity so
personally i don't believe that norway
did anything unethical about leveraging
its resources and the demand for oil
another major criticism against the fund
is that their ethical boundaries aren't
enough as a country many argue that they
have the responsibility of being a good
role model and only supporting
productive businesses one of the
industries that critics argue that funds
shouldn't be involved in is gambling and
betting this has actually been an
ongoing issue for many years now and
norway has taken steps to ban
investments in casinos but so far
nothing concrete has taken place and the
fund invested in draftkings as recently
as march 2021
and finally the third biggest criticism
against the fund is that it's controlled
by norgsbank nork's bank basically has
full control of the fund and as long as
they don't break any guidelines they can
do whatever they want the bank does have
500 well-qualified financial
professionals but at the end of the day
final investment decisions are left to
just 17 finance ministry bureaucrats
when the fund had less than 100 billion
dollars this wasn't a very big concern
but now that the fund is reaching into
the trillions these guys have
substantial financial power they could
use this power to prop up their own
investments and or manipulate the
markets aside from having a lot of power
many argue that these leaders aren't
actually that great when it comes to
investing and that hiring better leaders
would lead to far better returns while
all of these points are fair i don't
think you can complain too much given
how well the fund is performing in
comparison to the rest of the world
given how successful the sovereign
wealth fund has been for norway would it
be possible to apply such a system to
the us
well some states in the u.s already have
a sovereign wealth fund like alaska the
alaska permanent fund was created back
in 1976 and similar to the oil fund the
permanent fund is made possible through
oil revenue as of 2021 the fund had 81.9
billion worth of assets and they
dispersed roughly 1600 per year per
resident so clearly such a concept is
not foreign to the us however it would
be quite difficult to create a national
sovereign fund especially if it was
funded using new contributions and new
taxes here's the thing while such a
program would be extremely helpful to
people with bad spending habits and
little to no investment it's not all
that helpful for discipline savers and
investors
at the end of the day such a fund is
just going to match the market if that
so many would far prefer to just do that
themselves if such a fund was created
though it wouldn't be all that hard to
manage logistically for example if half
of social security's reserves were
converted into a wealth fund that would
entail investing about 1.5 trillion
dollars while that's a large amount it's
quite manageable within the financial
world after all blackrock has nearly 10
trillion dollars under management so
creating such a fund would definitely be
more of a political issue than a
logistical issue personally i'd be a fan
of converting social security into a
wealth fund given that any sort of
return would be better than social
security's zero percent real returns but
that's just what i think would you guys
support a sovereign wealth fund comment
that down below
also drop a like if you're a fan of
norway's wealth fund and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm ari and i'll see you guys on
the next one